سالنا كبار السن في الشارع الاردني هل
استخدامك للانترنت والتواصل مع الاخرين
عبر المنصات المختلفه يساعدك ويجلب لك
الراحه والسعاده ويؤثر على صحتك ماذا
اجابه خلونا نشوف
[موسيقى]
بالنسبه بالتاكيد لانه في اخبار بتكون
يعني
جديده بالنسبه الي وبتفاجئ فيها وبالتالي
بتشرب لي السعاده
ممكن تتواصل مع كل الناس يعني باكبر سرعه
ممكن تتواصل مع مجموعه كبيره من الاشخاص
بنفس الوقت نعم
يعني لما تصحى الصبح سعيد او زعلان وتفتح
التواصل الاجتماعي بيسمح لك انه تتواصل مع
مع اشي بعيد يعني ما بتتوقع انه كنت تحكي
معه او تشوفه او كذا عرفت شو مثلا ممكن
عائلتك اولادك اهلك كذا اصحابك اصدقاء
زمان ما شفتهم
[موسيقى]
لحد ما يعني بشكل نسوي بس بهالحد كبير
يعني بجيب السعاده بقرب لك البعيد
وبتتواصل مع الناس المغتربين
المهاجرين مش دايما لانه اول اشي ما
بيخلوا الاهل والقرايب والاصدقاء انهم
يزوروا بعض ثانيا
هو في ميزه بس وحده انها كويسه انك بتعرف
ايش وضع الناس مين اللي توفى مين صار عنده
مناسبه مين صار بس من خلالها
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات